now we have this incredible compilation
it's about a minute and a half disney
had an internal meeting of a ton of
higher-ups i'll tell you after we play
the clip who some of these people are
but a ton of higher-ups they did this
internal meeting about the don't say gay
bill and how they intend to continue
to to infect people with this woke
[ __ ] and it got exposed of course
because everything gets exposed of
course these days because things are on
zoom and everywhere else so just take a
look and listen to these series of
people
who they want your kids
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered
greetings in relationship to our life
skills so we no longer say ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls um we we've
trained we we've provided training for
all of our our cast members and in
relationship to that so now they know
it's it's hello everyone or hello
friends we we are in the process of
changing over those those recorded
messages and so many of you are probably
familiar when we brought the fireworks
back to the magic kingdom we no longer
say ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
we say dreamers of all ages i'm here as
a mother of two queer children actually
um uh one transgender child um
um and one pansexual child um and and
also as a leader
many many many lgbtqia characters
in our stories and
and and yet we don't have enough
leads
um and narratives in which gay
characters just just get to be
characters on my little pocket of like
you know proud family disney tva um the
showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard let's have
these two characters kiss let's in the
background like i was just wherever i
could just basically adding queerness to
like if you see anything queer in the
show i'm proud of them but like i just
was like no one would stop me and no one
was trying to stop me also reacting from
the reality that
when they can erase you when they can
criminalize your existence when they can
demonize who you are
the next step
is to criminalize you and take your kids
and we're already seeing that in texas
so the slippery slope between these ugly
messages
um you know emanating from legislative
leaders in our state and then amplified
by our governor whose spokesperson
immediately began calling everyone who
opposed this bill
uh groomers aka pedophiles yeah um i've
had the privilege of working with the
moon girl team for the last two years
and they've been really open to
exploring queer stories and so i put
together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like oh
all of our
like gender non-conforming characters
are in the background
okay so who are these people that just
spoke there i'm just gonna break it down
real quick the woman who said that
they're not gonna use gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen boys and girls anymore
that's disney's diversity and inclusion
manager vivian ware she's up there she
has a ridiculous amount of power because
all the kids that were going to disney
and that you know before you'd get on
the ride they were going boys and girls
line up get on the ride that was
actually causing hate and there were all
sorts of hate crimes they were murdering
children apparently because of that the
next lady who said that she has a
transgender child and a pansexual child
i don't know what that has to do with
her work at a giant corporation that's
disney corporate president carrie burke
um so congratulations you have those
kids that's just fine with me i don't
have a problem with gay people actually
i think it's a perfectly uh normal part
of society there are gay animals they
are gay human beings it's it's part of
the experience right it's it's an
outlier sexuality but it's part of the
thing but you think because you have
these kids that somehow that should
infect all of your work uh the next
person was disney executive producer
latoya revenue she said that she's
implementing her not-so-secret gay
agenda into all of the movies again this
has nothing to do with being anti-gay
but do you want your children to be
propagandized by people that are telling
you that they are activists and if
even remove gay from this whatever that
they would want to propagandize to your
children whatever thoughts they would
want your children to have they're
saying hey we operate
as a propaganda
outlet not as an entertainment outlet uh
the next person was disney's activism
partner nadine smith of equality
california she said that they want that
desantis wants to erase you criminalize
your existence and take your kids uh
again i had dinner with him last week um
there was no moment of taking my kids or
criminalizing me i had the stake it was
pretty good actually we went to this
place flaglers in west palm beach it was
really excellent i had a i had a
tomahawk they seared that thing just
freaking perfectly and desantis made
sure that i had dessert so uh that's
that's the reality of what's going on
here i want to give a quick shout out to
uh chris ruffo who you guys know he's
been on the show many times who is
exposing most of this i think he was the
one that got this video because he gets
all of these leakers at these companies
to send him videos and it's important to
know what these people are doing this
has nothing to do with being prejudiced
towards gay people this has nothing to
do with breaking up gay families or not
allowing a kid to say i have two dads or
that the parents can't come to the play
at the school or anything else this is
about transparency in education and
making sure that state employees cannot
infect children with whatever their
ideas are and then hide it from the
parents